in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio is professor manfred tetes of
Zetas head of an eye clinic here in
Berlin welcome to the show you know
there are different kinds of visual
problems one are very acute and others
are more long-lasting and gradually
increasing and with retina detection
it's a very acute situation and we saw
that is there's a procedure performed
but that's this procedure lasts forever
well the procedure consists of two
things closure of the hole and
reattachment of this very thin retina to
make the retina function again when the
hole is really closed and there is no
more traction the procedure will last
but there's instances where you need a
second or third surgery to reattach the
retina there is a risk that in an d
tetra dinner other holes may develop so
in the future the patient also has to
undergo examinations in to see the eye
doctor no regular basis yes yes and in
the first place who's that most at risk
for a retinal detention well the two
groups at a higher risk is the my hopes
because the eye is longer everything is
stretched and there's a higher risk for
tears or holes in the retina to develop
that will cause the detachment and
there's also eyes that have undergone
some trauma and you have some scarring
from the vitreous retina interface and
some traction and these sites and it can
lead to acute detachment following the
trauma or a later detachment when
secondary changes pull the written off
and how much time does a person have to
go and see an eye doctor with the
retinal detachment well the symptoms the
patient has maybe some some rain of dark
particles which is the bleeding inside
the eye or it may be like a curtain that
moves into the visual field
and the difference here is is the macula
the center of the vision still on or off
if the macula is off the prognosis and
the healing is much longer so the
patient should not wait till he cannot
see faces anymore I cannot read anymore
the moment he notices the symptoms he
should see the eye doctor actually it's
acute care and accident and emergency
now let's move on to retinal vein
occlusion it's a different kind of acute
visual disturbance it's very dangerous
and what are the warning signs here well
usually the patient has some hazy vision
and he sees everything like through a
very dense curtain it can be a small
area or a large area depending on what
vein is occluded and the risk factor
number one here is actually hypertension
because the veins and the arterioles
have a common connective tissue and if
there's high pressure on the arterial
side it includes the vein and the blood
cannot flow and has the treated well you
try to improve blood flow in this early
stage you can use infusions you can use
aspirin and a low dosage to make the
blood thinner it so it can flow better
but in general you have to treat the
symptoms which is the edema the swelling
if you have a trombonist in your leg it
swell so you have to treat the swelling
and the bleeding and this is usually
done by drugs which are injected inside
the eye
it's NTV HF which is one of the
components or some steroid components
that can help to reduce the swelling
eating lots of carrots can such a diet
really help prevent macular degeneration
well what we know from studies is that
if you take the lutein the 10 milligrams
per day and you have a beginning macular
degeneration you can certainly delay
disease by this nutritional agent the
books are not completely closed yet
whether just taking it I'd say at the
age of 50 or 60 because it's an
age-related disease will prevent it to
come on your cure at the age of 70 or 80
there is some evidence and some hints
but it's not completely clear yet so
it's not a general advice that every
elderly people eat a lot of
carrots and filled with nowadays modern
diet intake we have I think the 10
milligrams of lutein are something which
is useful more users and other things
and this is every single person at risk
for developing making a degeneration
over age as I mentioned it is an
age-related disease so the risk
increases above the age of 60 and this
also relates to the recommendations
above the age of 60 you should have your
macular checked like every one or two
years if you have no symptoms and if you
have symptoms you should have it checked
immediately and if you don't have
symptoms you can perform a little test
and we prepare the test for our viewers
and and yeah it that you have to move a
little bit closer now because we have
this grip with a little spot in the
middle of the grip and yeah please move
a little closer and um look at this grid
now with one eyes closed and with the
other eye at a distance of about 30 to
40 centimeters try to fixate on the dot
here in the middle if you can't see the
dot or if the lines of the grids are
curved or if you see dark or blurry
areas that could be signs of macular
degeneration and that means you should
go and see an eye doctor
but the problem is of course and that
all the TV sets can interfere with this
test so you can go to our website and
print this out and see the eye doctor
when what are the first symptoms you
have to go to see the eye doctor
well if you have blurry vision if you're
reading capability goes down if you see
straight lines oblique or in waves that
is actually symptoms when you should
start seeing your eye doctor usually
these symptoms come slowly but macular
degeneration can also have an acute
effect if you have a degeneration which
was mild and then you have an acute
bleeding your symptoms can become very
abrupt we've got a viewer from Costa
Rica he tree fly Donna and she has wet
macular degeneration gets regular
injections and those injections don't
help what should she do alternatives
well yes there's a dry stage which is
just the cells slowly dying and then
that's the wet stage of the macular
degeneration we're sick vessels start to
grow under the macula and these vessels
leak so
can bleed or the fluid can go into the
tissue and decrease your vision nowadays
we have modern medications which are
really drugs which are injected in the
eye
it's either antov HF which is a growth
factor inhibitor or it is some steroids
in the specific form that can reduce the
swelling of the the macula and they do
help in a lot of patients but
unfortunately not in all patients okay
and with what kind of visual
disturbances should you see the doctor
very very urgently and go to the A&E
what are the most threatening warning
signs the threatening warning signs any
sudden loss of vision or loss of visual
field any kind of things that happen
quite abruptly and if you losing vision
test your eyes individually you see the
vision is lost in the eye it's permanent
go and see your doctor correct or worse
that has - thanks so much for being with
us in the studio today you should
welcome
you